in the previous video you saw how you
can use mini-batch gradient descent to
start making progress to start taking
gradient descent steps even when you're
just partway through processing your
training set even for the first time in
this video you learn more details of how
to implement gradient descent and gain a
better understanding of what is doing
and why it works with batch gradient
descent on every iteration you go
through the entire training set and you
would expect the costs to go down on
every single iteration so if we plot the
cost function J as a function of
different iterations it should decrease
on every single iteration and if it ever
goes up even on one iteration then
something's wrong maybe the learning
rates too big on mini-batch gradient
descent though if you plot progress in
your cost function then it may not
decrease on every iteration in
particular on every iteration you're
processing some X T YT and so if you
plot the cost function J T which is
computed using just X T YT then it's as
if on every iteration you're training on
a different training cycle really
trading on a different meaning batch so
you plot the cost function J you're more
likely to see something that looks like
this
it should trend downwards but it is also
going to be a little bit noisier
you plot J of T has your training
mini-batch gradient descent it may be
over multiple epochs you might expect to
see a curve like this so as okay if it
doesn't go down on every iteration but
it should trend downwards and the reason
it'll be a little bit noisy is that
maybe x1 y1 it's just a relatively easy
meaning batch so your cost might be a
bit lower but then maybe just by chance
x2 y2 is just a harder mini batch maybe
even some let's label examples in it in
which case the cost would be a bit
higher and so on so that's why you get
these oscillations as you plot the cost
when you're running mini batch gradient
descent now one of the parameters you
need to choose is the size of your mini
batch so M was the training set size on
one extreme if the mini batch size is
equal to M then you just end up with
bosch gradient descent alright so in
this extreme you would just have one
mini batch x1 y1 and this mini batch is
equal to your entire training set so
setting the movie batch size M just
gives you back gradient descent the
other extreme would be if your mini
batch size were equal to 1 this gives
you an algorithm called stochastic
gradient descent and here every example
is his own mini batch so what
in this case as you look at you know the
first mini batch so x1 y1 but when you
meanie batch sizes 1 this just has you
know your first training example and you
take your it into sense that with your
first training example and then you mix
take a look at your second mini batch
which is just your second training
example and take your grandest and step
with that and then you do with the third
training example and so on looking at
just one single training example at a
time so let's look at what these two
extremes will do on optimizing this cost
function if these are the contours of a
cost function trying to minimize so the
your minimum is there then - gradient
descent might start somewhere and be
able to take relatively low noise
relatively large steps and you know just
keep marching to the minimum in contrast
with so costly gradient descent if you
start somewhere let's pick a different
starting point then on every iteration
you're taking bring descends with just a
single training example so most of the
time you hit to what the global minimum
but sometimes you hit in the wrong
direction if you know that one example
happens to point you in a bad direction
so stochastic great descent can be
extremely noisy and on average takes you
in a good direction but um sometimes
you're headed in the wrong direction as
well as the constant descent won't ever
converge you're always just kind of
oscillate and wander around the region
of the minimum but it won't ever just
head to the minimum and stay there
in practice the mini batch size you use
will be somewhere in between
some moves in in 1 + M + 1 nm are
respectively too small and too large and
here's why if you use batch gradient
descent
so this is your mini batch size equals M
then you're processing a huge training
set on every innovation so the main
disadvantage of this is that it takes
too much time too long per iteration
assuming you have a very large training
set if you have you're a small training
set then bachelor in descent is fine if
you go to the opposite if you use the
conflict-ridden you're sent then it's
nice that you get to make progress after
processing just one example that's
actually not a problem and the noisiness
can be ameliorated or can be reduced by
just using a smaller learning rate but
the huge disadvantage the stochastic
green descent is that you lose almost
all your speed up from vectorization
because here you're processing a single
training example at a time the way you
process each example is going to be very
inefficient so what works best in
practice is something in between where
you have some you know mini batch size
that not too big or too small and this
gives you impractical fastest learning
and you notice that this has two good
things going for it one is that you do
get a lot of vectorization so in the
example we use on the previous video if
your mini batch size was a thousand
examples then you know you might go to
vectorize across a thousand examples so
it's going to be much faster than
processing the examples one at a time
and second you can also make progress
without needing to wait
till you process the entire training set
so again using the numbers we have in
the previous video in epochal each path
to your training set allows you to take
5000 gradient descent steps so in
practice there be some in-between mini
batch size that works best and so with
mini bearing assembly to start here
maybe one iteration does this two
iterations three four you know and it's
not a guarantee to always head toward
the minimum but it tends to head more
consistently in the rational minimum
than stochastic during descent and then
it doesn't always exactly convert your
oscillate in a very small region if
that's an issue you can always reduce
the learning rate slowly we'll talk more
about learning rate detail how to reduce
our learning rate in a later video so if
the mini batch size should not be M and
should not be one but it should be
something in between how do you go about
choosing it well here are some
guidelines first if you have a small
training set just use batch gradient
descent you know if you have the small
training set then no point using the
batch render send you can process the
whole training site quite fast so you
might as well use factory innocent what
the small training set mean I would say
you know this less than maybe 2000 um
would be perfectly fine to just use
battery and descent otherwise if you
have a bigger training set typical mini
batch sizes would be anything from 64 up
to maybe 512 are quite typical and
difference of the way computer memory is
laid out in Access sometimes you code
runs faster if your mini batch size is a
lot as the power of two alright so 64 is
2 to the 6 to the 7 2 to the 8 2 to the
9 so often I'll implement my mini batch
size to be a power of 2 I know in the
previous video I use in the batch size
of 1000 if you really want to do that
work
you just use zero 1024 which is to the
power of 10
and you do see mean batch sizes of size
1024 it is a bit more rare this range of
mini batch size is a little bit more
common one last tip is to make sure that
your mini batch all of your XT comma Y T
that that fits in you know CPU GPU
memory and this really depends on your
application and how large the single
training example is but if you ever
process a mini batch that doesn't
actually fit in CPU GPU memory whatever
using the process the data then you find
that the performance suddenly falls off
a cliff and is suddenly much worse so I
hope this gives you a sense of the
typical range of mini batch sizes that
people use in practice of course the
mini batch size is actually another
hyper parameter that you might do a
quick search over to try to figure out
which one is most efficient at reducing
your cost function J so what I would do
is just try a several different values
try a few different powers of two and
then see if you could pick one that
makes your gradient descent optimization
algorithm as efficient as possible but
hopefully this gives you a set of
guidelines for how to get started with
that type of parameter search you now
know how to implement mimi bash great
descent and make your algorithm run much
faster especially when you're trading on
a large training set but it turns out
they're even more efficient algorithms
than gradient descent or mini battery in
this end let's start talking about them
in the next few videos